today on the matt wall show the mask
wars are driving people
insane uh but the mask issue should not
be ideological and doesn't need to be
a battleground in the culture war so
today i hope to inject a little bit of
basic common sense into the mask debate
because a lot of that is lacking also
five headlines including crazed
taylor swift fans doxing a music
reviewer who didn't like
taylor swift's album enough she liked it
but not enough and so she got doxxed
and in our daily cancellation i'll
preemptively cancel the false narrative
around the latest video
of a man dying in police custody i have
the video footage we'll talk about it
of course there's a lot of false
narratives already cropping up all of
that
coming up okay beginning here look
usually i save the daily cancellation
for the end of the show and
and we will have one at the end of the
show but today is going to be a rare
double cancellation we will cancel at
the beginning and at the end
and who knows maybe in the middle too
you never know what i really like to do
is cancel
any and all mask cultists on
either side okay pro mask anti-mask
anyone who intentionally makes a scene
in public over masks pro or anti is
canceled
anyone on a crusade to spread the good
news or
bad news about masks is canceled anyone
who even
talks about masks is cancelled i'm so
sick of it which means that i'm
cancelled too fine this is a this is a
kamikaze
mission on my part this whole mask thing
is driving people quite literally insane
uh masks have become somehow
a societal touchstone a battleground for
the culture war
which i suppose shouldn't surprise me i
mean even butter and syrup and chicken
sandwiches have been battleground for
the culture war
in recent times um but now masks have
become a way
for both sides of the culture to to to
to to signal their allegiance you know
they have become a way to
identify the in-group and the out-group
pro-mask first anti-mask the two tribes
because everything is tribal these days
so i want to show you the latest example
this is um
a video uh pretty disturbing in a lot of
ways this is from a walmart
in georgia in georgia watch this
you take care of yourself
[Music]
yes you heard that right the old woman
in the mask wishes
death on the family that doesn't have a
mask
to include the small children she wishes
death on small children because they
aren't wearing masks
like i said driven insane she says i
hope you all die because you're going to
kill me
now even if that were true what kind of
adult
especially older adult wishes death on
small children in order to preserve
their own lives
you know this four-year-old must die so
that i can live another few years
and be miserable and selfish the whole
time i have to spread my
i still have so much more misery and
selfishness to spread throughout the
earth
um then again i shouldn't be shocked
because a similar thought process has
led to the murder of 60 million children
in the womb in this country so what else
could i
really expect and also for the record of
course
she is not going to die because those
people aren't wearing masks
she is going to die at some point we all
will but it's not going to be because
that family wasn't wearing a mask
she's wearing a mask all she has to do
now is avoid them
walk in the other direction if anyone in
that family has the virus
it isn't going to jump out of their
mouths and travel through the store
through the aisles to attack her while
she's over in the raisin bran aisle or
whatever she's doing
so if you're really worried that that uh
about people who aren't wearing masks
why are you in their face yelling at
them just walk away give them
space isn't that what you would do if
you're afraid someone has a deadly
disease
but let's be fair here okay pro mask
cultists
aren't the only ones making scenes in
public i'll show you another video
this is a video and there are many like
it of a guy at a grocery store in
california
going crazy screaming at employees who
are
simply trying to enforce uh their
company mask policy watch
get away from me
[Music]
you need to leave right now
there you go
[Music]
outside now
that is not a random person harassing
that guy okay this is an employee
works for the establishment they were
being perfectly reasonable
he's being a lunatic okay
now i want to make a few points about
masks
and if i'm lucky i'll piss off everybody
on all sides of this infernal debate um
we'll start with this number one masks
are not magical cloths that guarantee
you safety from all
all harm in fact the science is not
settled at all
on how effective the masks actually are
that's why the government originally
told us
not to wear them scratch that didn't
just tell us not to wear them but
aggressively scolded and shamed anyone
who did wear them you may remember this
tweet from the surgeon general in
february
i said seriously people stop buying
masks all cabs
they are not effective in preventing
general public from catching coronavirus
but if healthcare providers don't get to
get don't get them to care for the sick
patients it puts
them and our communities at risk so if
if the government has trouble getting
people to buy into masks
they only have themselves to blame and a
little bit of acknowledgement and
accountability on that score
would be nice after all they were again
the ones going out and
shaming people for wearing masks for
months until they changed their tune
number two
masks are also not a communist
conspiracy to control and oppress you
a federal mask mandate requiring people
to wear masks all the time everywhere in
the country
would be bad news and i certainly and
certainly unconstitutional and i would
oppose it passionately
but in most cases even aside from what
the local ordinances say retail outlets
and other stores
have their own policies requiring masks
and a big reason they do that
is to cover their own butts against
liability someone's going to get sued
because
a customer got coronavirus in their
store nobody wants to be the company
that that deals with that lawsuit
that's perfectly reasonable as far as i
can tell and if i was in their shoes
i'd probably do the same thing walking
into a store that requires
requests masks and making a point of not
wearing them
just makes you a jackass not a freedom
fighter
these establishments have the right to
set the rules respect that
or go elsewhere also by the way when you
go
charging into a store without a mask all
you're doing is causing problems for the
kid at the entrance
who's supposed to be enforcing the rule
or as was the case in the video i just
played for the young lady who who has to
enforce it
you're just getting him in trouble or
her in trouble and making their lives
more difficult that makes you a jerk not
a hero i mean who do you think you're
standing up against you're standing up
against
you know an employee that gets paid nine
dollars an hour just causing problems
for them
number three you're not a hero for
wearing a mask
either it's not a sign of virtue it
doesn't make you a good person
people who don't wear masks aren't evil
uh if they aren't wearing them in a
store that requires them they're being
jerks to the store employees but they
aren't demon spawns
i mean the guy in the video kind of
acted like one a little bit but but but
most
aren't and uh they aren't a re they
aren't any real threat to your health
either just give them a wide berth if
you're concerned you'll be fine
if it's a situation where masks are not
required
as is the case in most of the
establishments where i happen to live
then people will make their own
decisions and you should mind your own
damn business
personally i don't wear a mask unless
it's required that's my choice
my business you make your own choice and
if you're petrified to leave your home
unless every human
everywhere is wearing a mask then you
suffer from paranoid delusions
and you should probably seek
psychological care coronavirus
is the least of your problems you insane
person
number four wearing masks outside while
you walk down the sidewalk
is very stupid and pointless and in 100
degree heat
probably not sanitary with all the sweat
and everything that's gathering in there
you're not going to contract or spread
the coronavirus while walking
past someone outside the virus according
to the cdc and all research we've seen
is mostly spread through close and
prolonged contact
with symptomatic people that accounts
for the vast majority of infections your
chance of getting it outside walking
down the road is extremely extremely
extremely
small but again make your own choices
you know it's up to you
number five actually there is no five
four is quite enough my point is made
um those are all of my opinions about
masks
i have no more opinions i don't know how
many
how people have so many opinions and so
strongly
about masks this is one of those things
as i said at the top
where i wish we could all just have just
a little bit of common sense that's all
just just apply a little bit of normal
common sense to the situation
and um and i think we'll be
we'll be okay all right let's move on to
our five
headlines
[Music]
we're going to go through these
headlines here remember um there's so
much going on in the news if you want to
keep up with all of it
make sure to get a reader's pass at
dailywire.com go to dailywire.com
subscribe today
and that will give you access to all of
our exclusive content
uh minus the the mainstream media left
to spin
get exclusive op-eds from your podcast
hosts as well as guest writers in-depth
analysis from daily wire reporters
um on top of all the regular breaking
news as well the membership tier is
three dollars a month but you can get
your first month for 99 cents so go to
dailywire.com subscribe and join today
okay um where are we number one
a hologram effigy of george floyd will
be
touring the southern states to be
projected onto confederate monuments in
georgia north carolina
virginia other places floyd's family
members
are behind this project and they
unveiled it at a ceremony in richmond
i think it was yesterday and it was
projected over a jefferson davis
memorial
the daily news the daily news describes
the hologram this way says the hologram
starts out with
fireflies that coalesce into a 3d image
of floyd with his name depicted in
graffiti on either side to reflect the
murals
that have sprung up worldwide now
okay i want you to imagine how
traumatizing this must be
legitimately traumatizing for george
floyd's victims
and yes he did have victims um
just how how would you feel think about
how you would feel
put yourself in the shoes of his victims
think about the woman
who was robbed at gunpoint by floyd
after he forced his way into her
house held a gun to her stomach in front
of her child
how would she feel how would you feel if
that happened to you
seeing the giant face of your attacker
glowing and projected onto a memorial
like you some kind of
heavenly vision
uh this as as i've been saying for a
while now you know we we have gone
of course way way way beyond
just uh expressing outrage over an
unjust
death this this is way into the realm of
canonizing sanctifying hero worship
of a man who was to put it really mildly
not a hero at all um
[Music]
but this is what we're doing let's go to
number two
here's a a fun story reading from the
new york post it says a suspected
arsonist faces up to 20 years in jail
for trying to torch portland's justice
center
and he was and i hope he actually does
all 20 years which which but i think we
know that's not going to happen
uh he was easily identified thanks to a
tattoo of his name on his back according
to prosecutors edward
edward shinzing 32 was one of 30 who
broke into the area that houses the
city's police headquarters
under the cover of protests in late may
the mob attack led to the area later
being secured with heavy gates
after smashing windows the mob spray
painted offices
broke computers and then started a
series of fires in a jail records office
forcing staff to flee for safety um
shinzing was according to the police
department identified by a comparison
with a jail booking photo and a
distinctive tattoo
of his last name across his back um
a booking photograph shows his surname
in large letters across his back
seemingly matching those of a topless
intruder caught in security camera
footage
from the attack uh yeah and
unfortunately
for for him his last name is shinzing
like at least if it was smith or johnson
or something like that he could
maybe claim that the guy in the footage
is someone else someone with his last
name who looks just like him
and also has the same tattoo it's not a
very plausible denial but at least it's
possible
uh it's more possible than claiming that
there's more than one qinzing in the
area
uh up to mischief i'll never understand
of
of all the the dumb tattoos people get i
will never understand getting a tattoo
of your own name
this is a somewhat common thing and i i
just don't get it it's
it's pretty lazy for one thing it seems
as though you went to the tattoo
parlor sat down
had no idea what you wanted and then
came up with this on the spot
it's like the tattoo artist so what do
you want um
i don't know i hadn't really thought
about it i mean
my name let's just go with that
but of course that's not how tattoos
work you know maybe it works that way in
like prison i don't know but
in the in the free world it's a slower
and more considered process
and yet you settle on your own name and
though
and then you go and commit crimes with
your shirt off
exposing your name antifa
antifa they are not sending their best
uh they really aren't or maybe this is
their best
which is a scary thought number three
the actress uh i think she's an actress
tiffany haddish appeared on carmella
anthony's
carmelo anthony's show yesterday come on
anthony of course the basketball player
apparently has his own show everybody
does these days
they even gave one to me i mean it's
pretty easy to get one
and during the discussion at one point
she explained why she doesn't want to
bring
kids into this world and speaking of
being paranoid
listen to this i'm not a fearful person
right but like i have watched many of my
friends not many but
more than two of my friends growing up
be killed by police officers
you know and and it makes you feel like
dang
you know as a black person we were being
hunted
and like i felt like and i've always
felt like that we're hunted and we're
slaughtered
and it's like they get this license to
kill us and that's not okay
and you know now i'm i'm older now
a little older and people are like
you're gonna have baby when you're gonna
have some babies when you're gonna drop
some babies and
and there's a part of me that would
would like to do that and i always make
up these excuses like oh i need a
million dollars in the bank before i can
touch you
i need this i need that but really it's
like
i would hate to give birth to someone
that looks like me
and then knowing that they're gonna be
hunted or killed
you know like why would i put someone
through that look i know it doesn't
matter at this point
uh nope nobody nobody cares it we're way
past the point
when things like facts make a difference
to anyone
but for the record this police are
hunting
people down thing is completely and
totally untrue um
not even a little true there is
literally
zero truth to it it never happens
so when someone says police are hunting
and killing uh black people
it's not just that they're exaggerating
it's that they're inventing something
that never happens
certainly not in recent history unless i
mean prove me wrong
give me an example give me an example if
you have one
of police going out and hunting and
killing a black
person um now there are cases of people
of police killing people obviously
in the vast majority of those cases the
people who are killed were in the
process of trying to kill officers
that's true as as we have gone over even
of the unarmed killings
in most of those cases uh the the
the person was trying to kill officers
either by using a
uh a weapon that doesn't count as a
weapon in the official reports like a
vehicle
or by trying to disarm them take their
weapon and use it against them that sort
of thing
and in the very very very very small
minority of
of actual unjust killings
none of them that i've ever heard of
could be honestly described as police
hunting and killing someone you want to
say that george floyd killing was unjust
fine if you say that that the man was
hunted and killed then you're just a
dishonest ridiculous hack
and i think you know that
um number four the daily beast has a
report now
about the insane backlash a music review
for the site pitchfork faced her name
the reviewer named
jillian mapes and mapes wrote a positive
but mildly critical review of taylor
swift's new album
folklore i think it's called and because
it wasn't positive enough
swift's fans harassed her actually doxed
her according to the daily beast
posted her address and her phone number
um doxed her because that she didn't
like taylor swift's album
enough she liked it but didn't like it
enough
you know she gave whatever b minus or
something whatever her grade was and it
wasn't an
a plus you know it's not good enough
this is why of all the lost souls of all
the deranged groups of people in america
and there are many of them
none are more lost or more deranged than
people who find their
their identity in their fandom
you know whether they're fans of a pop
star or a movie like star wars or a tv
show or video games whatever it is
um there's nothing wrong with being a
fan okay i'm a fan believe it or not
there are there are things and people
that i like
if you can believe it not many but there
are some what i'm talking about is
finding your identity
in your fandom if that's like the most
important thing
to you in your life for that to be
basically
the number one thing about you the most
prominent component of your life
is that you're a fan of this thing or
this person
uh if you fall into that category then
you are no offense
the most pathetic sort of person that
it's possible to be
the phrase get a life was invented for
you specifically
um and here's how to know that you're in
that group okay maybe maybe maybe you're
not sure if you're if you're that far
into it
um here's how to know you're in that
group or you're you're headed in that
direction you're nearly in that group
if you get angry actually truly
angry when someone doesn't like a form
of entertainment that you like
you know if you are incapable of having
a discussion with someone
who is critical of your favorite thing
or who doesn't like as much as you
if you cannot engage with any critical
discussion of this thing or person that
you like
uh because you become blind with fury
and start to feel real hatred towards
that person
that's a good sign that you are way way
too invested
in this thing whatever it is and yes
that goes for sports teams too i will
throw that in
not gonna leave that out and i say that
as someone who sometimes teeters close
to the edge of being a pathetic loser in
this regard i admit that
i do take my fandom of the baltimore
ravens
quite seriously too seriously in fact
and um
and so yes i am kind of a pathetic loser
there but but the saving grace is that
it only lasts for four months out of the
year
uh so for four months of the year i'm a
pathetic dork
when it comes to the you know my
football fandom but then i revert back
to being normal
again for for the rest of it so it's
only a third of the year okay for me
being pathetic it's not too bad it's not
great but
it's it's not as bad as it could be but
even as seriously as i take sports
you know i still don't take it as
seriously as some people do
you know i've seen a not unfamiliar
sight people get into fist fights i mean
many of us have seen this if you're at a
a stadium or a sportswear i was at a
sports bar a little while ago and
two dudes in different team jerseys got
into a fight
now granted there was alcohol involved
okay but but even so
um i've never been tempted to punch
someone because they liked a different
team than me
think about what that is okay you're
you're trying to cause physical harm to
someone
because they like to watch a different
group of men play a game oh yeah
this group of men are better at playing
the game than
than your favorite group no they're not
no this group is even better you bastard
i'll kill you
i mean it's just it's it's not stable is
all i'm saying it really does
stop and think about what you're doing
every once in a while
um okay number five this is this is good
to report from the new york post
um says let me read a little bit it says
there's some real monkey business at a
british safari park where a roving gang
of baboons
armed with knives and even a chainsaw
have been wreaking havoc and sowing fear
according to a report
the prowling primates are known to have
vandalized vehicles
uh ripping off windshield wipers and
mirrors from them at the
knolls noseley safari park
uh but the baboons now i'm just reading
through here
oh this is disappointing i should have
read this before
now park officials are saying that it's
uh it's a myth
the park told the news outlet we believe
many of these stories have grown in
exaggeration as they've been retold
with embellishment to make the objects
that are sometimes found in the
enclosure
seem more exciting and unbelievable ah
that's disappointing
this is what i get for just going with
the headline usually i try to do better
than that usually i try to you know i
i i try not to be one of those people
that just
sees a headline and i'm off to the races
but when the headline is
chainsaw wielding baboons i'm going with
the headline
okay because and this is exactly why
then you read the details
and it's it's depressing because it
turns out maybe that's not actually the
case
i i like the idea though okay this is
what i want to say this is good because
i think we can all agree right that it's
it's probably time to wrap up this whole
humanity deal
like i think we've all it's it's we've
we've all seen enough
we've really run our course and milked
it for what it's worth and uh
it's probably time to just you know get
on with it get on with the apocalypse
one way or another
so it's just a matter now choosing the
best apocalypse okay how do we want to
finally self-destruct and a planet of
the apes type of thing could be a lot of
fun
now if i had my pick of the of the
litter i would still go with the alien
invasion but
if that's not going to happen if my
dreams are dashed um
then i think yeah arm the baboons maybe
do a little genetic manipulation type of
thing like they do in the movies
and just let them go to work um not a
bad way for the human species to
go out i think you have to admit so
those are our five headlines let's go to
our
daily cancellation today for our daily
cancellation i'm going to be canceling
preemptively all the false narratives
current and future um over the latest
incident of a suspect dying while police
attempt to restrain him during an arrest
this is lionel mor morris he died on
february 4th at a grocery store
as police tried to place him under
arrest uh the media
is running with the story the usual
suspects are
uh chiming in another george floyd
they're saying
the washington post headline is clearly
meant to give a certain impression
their headline if you can talk you can
breathe arkansas cops
tell man who later dies in police
custody
okay but all you need to do is read the
washington post article the actual
article not just the headlines speaking
of actually reading articles
to see the truth so let's uh
let's let's do that now let's let's look
at the this is like the second paragraph
of the article it says
morris had run from officers on february
4th and then placed one officer in a
chokehold and tried to pull out a knife
according to police
after the supermarket had reported him
for removing a drone from its packaging
i.e he was trying to steal it um but as
an officer had his knee on this 39 year
old's
back inside harps food store morris
handcuffed and lying face down
repeatedly offered a succinct and
familiar plea
i can't breathe there's body cam footage
and surveillance footage that has been
released and you can see it online
prosecutors cleared the officers of any
wrongdoing
in the case and that's why it's um in
the news now and that's why the footage
uh the footage was released the footage
shows why
there was no there there are no charges
in this case the body cam video is 45
minutes long i'm not going to play the
whole thing of course
but but here's a here's how the arrest
began at least we'll play this and
you'll see just the beginning of it you
can go on youtube to see the rest but
here's how the the arrest started
okay now put your hands on your back
all right what's up on your back come on
sir please
okay put it back there
oh
now you can't see a lot of the details
there but you can tell he's running
obviously
fighting the officer ends up on his back
and we're told morris tried to pull a
knife
put an officer in a chokehold um
also here's here's uh
there's there's other information about
this story that's important this also is
from the post but it's buried deeper
down in the article it says
uh the medical examiner concluded that
morris died of methamphetamine
intoxication with a combination of
exertion struggle
restraint and conducted uh electrical
weapon deployment
uh according to a letter from
prosecuting attorney carol cruz to
explain his death in custody
tapeley pointed to toxicology reports
finding that morris had substances
including methamphetamine morphine
amphetamine opioids opiates and
cannabinoids in his system
okay so a whole bunch of drugs to review
here
morris died because he was trying to
steal something
cops were called they tried to arrest
him because theft is illegal fyi
he ran assaulted officers tried to use a
deadly weapon
and all of that commotion eventually
killed him due in large part to the
cocktail of illegal drugs
that he had put into his body who is to
blame here
is it the cops who tried to arrest a man
who committed a crime and then defended
themselves against his violent attack
or is it the man who took a bunch of
drugs tried to steal something
then attacked the officers who came to
arrest him who should we blame
it's a tough call isn't it actually no
it's not
it's not a tough call at all um this
this is pretty straightforward and
amid all this talk about accountability
holding police accountable how about
some very basic accountability
for people like lionel morris
why in all of these cases that part of
it is always left out
what could the cops have done
differently okay
what could lionel morris have done
differently i can think of
dozens of things he could have done
differently um
certainly several big ones like don't
steal
uh if you do steal and the cops come
okay they have every right to arrest you
you are trying to commit a crime we live
in a civilized society we have laws if
you break them you get arrested
so don't run if you do try to make a run
for it which seems like a really bad
idea
because you're you're you know first of
all the woman that you're with is
is is is not running so they've got her
they're going to find you
you're on surveillance footage you're
not going to you're not going to get
away
so running makes no sense at all there's
no reason to do it
uh but so don't do that even if you do
do that don't then assault the police
officer when they finally catch up to
you
um and even if you do all of those
things
don't take a bunch of potentially lethal
drugs ahead of time that could
uh you know result in your death i mean
that's that's a list of what four or
five
things that lionel morris could have
done differently and if he had made a
different choice
on any one of those things okay just
just if you
take any one of those points if you had
made a different choice
he'd be alive today and it's it's not a
high bar
either right like don't take a bunch of
drugs try to steal something and then
assault the officers who come to arrest
you
that is not a high bar to get over
it it's not like we're expecting
something
unreasonable of lionel morris in this
case
he made a whole series of really really
bad choices
and then he died it's very sad
it's like you know it's it's always sad
when someone dies it's always sad
especially
when someone chooses to throw their own
life away for no reason
you know any death is sad but a death
because because you wanted to buy
yourself a
a few minutes of not being in custody
after you tried to steal a drone from a
grocery store it's like
you're going to throw your life away
over that it's it's
it's a really sad thing but it's not
a moral outrage there's no injustice
here
so we we know what lionel morris could
have done differently
very obvious if you want to start
picking apart the police officers and
monday morning quarterbacking it
uh what what could they have done
differently
let's go through the chain of events on
the part of the officers
they get a call that someone's trying to
steal at a store
they respond to the call we all agree
they should do that right
they're not gonna ignore it um they show
up to the scene
they investigate the situation okay we
all agree they should do that right
they're going to go up to
lionel morris and the woman that he's
with they're going to ask some questions
uh they find that he that he's removed
the drone from the packaging
and left it you know on a shelf and has
put the drone somewhere
pretty good evidence that he's trying to
steal it you don't do that if you're
planning to pay for it um so now they
know
or it seems very clear that he's that he
was trying to commit a crime
uh so they're going to arrest him is is
that a problem i mean
he was trying to commit a crime again we
do live in a civilized society with laws
i know the left would prefer if we
didn't but we do
and it's their job to enforce them so
they try to arrest them
so far they've done nothing wrong okay
now let's compare
the chain of events we've got you know
parallel actions and choices of the
officers
and lionel morris it's parallel until
they intersect
these parallel choices so far the
officers have done nothing wrong
lionel morse already has made a series
of really bad choices
taking a bunch of drugs trying to steal
something
and now there's the intersection they
try to make the arrest
he runs what do they do here do you
expect them to say oh never mind oh he's
he's running guys forget it forget it
forget it let's go
of course they're going to chase him
they have to he's they're trying to
arrest him he ran away because
the only other option there is to say
well uh
if you get arrested and you run then
you're you're home free
we might as well not have police at that
point so they tried to chase them down
uh can't blame him for that
once they get him now he's someone who's
resisting
you know this is this is a big this is a
man this is a you know
a a younger you know this is not like a
young
child that they're trying to apprehend
here this is a grown man that they're
trying to apprehend
he obviously is resisting so they have
to use force to bring him down
now he's putting them in chokeholds he's
trying to grab for a weapon
he is now a lethal threat to them
and so they don't pull out a gun and
shoot him they try to use a taser they
use less lethal means
um and and finally they get him down and
they're just they're holding him
on the ground while they try to cuff him
amid all that chaos we've already
established that leading up to
the chaos the officers did everything
right i mean there's nothing what else
could they have done
while lionel morris was doing everything
wrong but even amid all the cases what
else do you want them to do they
they're trying to it's it's a difficult
thing if you've never tried to do it
i've never done it but
i i i'll put it this way i'll take the
police word for it that
when you're trying to cuff a grown man
who doesn't want to be cuffed that's a
difficult thing it's not it's not it's
not easily done
and it requires some force that seems
logical to me i could i'll buy that i
could believe that
and so yes they've gotten down the
ground they've got a they're not on his
neck
they've got a knee on the back how else
are they going to affect the arrest what
else do you want them to do
and then he dies because largely
he was he was on a cocktail of drugs if
he wasn't on those drugs he'd be alive
um so it just seems pretty obvious to me
who is uh
who's responsible here and
maybe at a certain point we could start
just holding people accountable not just
police officers
other people too accountable for their
own actions a really basic bar
that we could say to people you know you
really got to get over that bar
society expects that of you i think that
should be our
our message as well so that false
narrative is canceled
a lot of cancellations today been been
good a lot of fun
we'll leave it there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
big tech big brother is watching you joe
biden continues to enjoy his
year-long weekend at bernie's and male
feminists continue to show
how creepy they really are check it out
on the michael knowles show